تعد دبابات ليبرد اثنان الالمانيه
الموجوده في نحو 20 دوله من افضل
المجنزرات في الغرب فهي من دبابات القتال
الرئيسيه وتبلغ سرعتها القصوى نحو 70 كم
في الساعه تزن الدبابه اكثر من 60 طن وهي
مزوده بمدفع من عيار 120 ملم ويمكنها
اصابه الاهداف على مسافه تصل الى خمسه
كيلومترات وتوصف بانها مزيج من الحمايه
والتنقل والقدره على المناوره اما دبابات
تشالنجر اثنان البريطانيه فتزين اكثر من
62 طنا وهي مزوده بمدفع من عيار 120م قادر
على اختراق الدروع وهي دبابه رئيسيه في
الجيش البريطاني تحتوي على درع يؤمن لها
حمايه عاليه وقادر على تحمل الانفجارات
الضخمه
ساعات برازيل الامريكيه تزن اكثر من 27
طنا وهي مزوده بمدفع من عيار 25 ملم
وصواريخ خارقه للدروع تستخدم لنقل الافراد
ولها قدره على الاستطلاع والمناوره
والاشتباك وتحتوي على دروع مضاده للالغام